what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about things marvel and
mcu and we just got trolled big time by
tom holland and
jacob battle on both of them today
posted to their instagram stating that
they have
officially revealed the title for
spider-man 3. tom holland posted his
first and we all began to
absolutely freak out on his instagram
post he said
so excited to announce the new
spider-man title can't wait for you lot
to see what we have been up to
love from atlanta then in his second
photo on the post he revealed a title
sequence that said
spider-man phone home now originally i
did think it was a joke because phone
home is clearly an
e.t reference and i did think it was
kind of random that he just
randomly revealed the title on instagram
with no warning whatsoever
but then jacob battalon posted to his
instagram account
we're excited to share the title of our
new movie swipe right for the big reveal
also enjoy this exclusive still from the
movie
just an extra gift from us and his title
was
different it said spider-man homewrecker
a title that i don't think
disney would ever allow now this is a
huge troll on behalf of tom and jacob
but
it's actually to get us hyped and
excited for what is to come
tom holland is actually going to be on
the tonight show starring jimmy fallon
and he's going to be on it
tonight so this could be a little bit of
a teaser as to what's to come tonight
tom holland
is most likely going to reveal the
official title the real official title
not a
joking around title of spider-man
homecoming 3 and we don't know if it's
going to be
a multiverse teaser title we don't know
if we're going to get maybe a picture
or maybe a slight teaser for spider-man
3 tonight
i would keep your hopes low it's not
even confirmed that they're going to
reveal a title even though the fact that
these two were messing around and
jokingly
teasing a title means that we probably
are getting the title but i would keep
your hopes
low as far as footage is concerned so
the two fake titles right now
are homewrecker and phone home what do
you think the official title will be
it looks like this is your last chance
to call it and state what you think it's
going to be so let me know in the
comments down below
also don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you can get
notified
right when we find out what the official
title is i'll be posting a video about
it tonight
so keep a heads up and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
wolf wolf